the new Call of Duty is out this week
kind of like Jess McDonald hi chris
waters I'm here to tell you that the
futuristic battlefields of black ops 3
are full of some really weird stuff now
I'm not talking like isn't it weird that
it took black ops this long to you the
Rolling Stones peanut black and their
marketing materials weird i'm talking
like weird if you've been to a gym or an
office building or a rocket league
stadium recently you've probably come to
realize that large balls are now a part
of your daily life but as with all
technology ever created those balls will
soon learn how to kill and kill they
will in a new score street reward called
robotic anti-personnel century or wraps
for short like your life will be once
someone calls in the wraps even though
they have spiky bits and have been known
to run a dude down anyone who saw wraps
in action in the black ops 3 beta knows
that they pretty much just scoot up next
to you and explode and they hunt in
packs clever wraps parkour isn't that
weird i mean if you saw your mom do it
it'd probably be weird but that's true
about a lot of things thanks to recent
games like titanfall and advanced
warfare we're pretty much down with the
idea of soldiers flinging themselves
about with only the loosest respect for
gravity but black ops 3 makes things
weird by plunging armored warriors into
a pool of water and being like yeah
those dudes can swim definitely forty
percent of their body is metal no big
deal they've probably got like a swim
bladder in there not weird at all ah yes
it is and even more odd are the giant
cubes of water you encounter in the new
free run mode these surreal agility
courses are designed to test your skills
with the new movement systems and hey
you might even get some ideas about how
to catch your opponents by surprise or
at least get your free running fix while
you continue to wait for the delayed yet
again Mirror's Edge catalyst so close
and yet so far I believe in equal
opportunity on the battlefield men women
robotic ly enhanced men and women with
boring old Robo human limbs instead of
wicked cool Robo animal limbs and robots
should all be able to shoot each other
to their hearts or Robo hearts content
but when they start meddling with the
laws of physics that maintain the very
order of the universe and I just don't
know the new specialist weapons and
abilities allow for some pretty
out-there stuff and none of them are
weirder than glitch activate this power
and you're instantly teleported to where
you were a few seconds ago teleported
weird use it to pop into a room drop a
grenade and pop out use it to evade
enemy fire use it to ambush unsuspecting
foes use it to fracture your opponent's
very conception of reality and begin
slowly unraveling their psyche some
might say this is too weird but to them
i say here is jeff goldblum as a film
noir magician killing his wife for
insurance money and getting cursed with
a case of the zombies we're way fast too
weird or are we of all the myriad ways
Call of Duty has let you kill digital
people over the years two of the most
bizarre are coming in black ops 3 here's
one bees oh the bees okay technically
not B's but nanobots that you send forth
from your person like a wizard from an
undersea dystopia only they're more
sanitary because they are robots and
more inflammatory the Firefly swarm is
one of the cyber Corps abilities you can
use in the campaign as is the sonic
anti-personnel now that may sound a bit
dry but as you'll see there's nothing
dry about it because it makes people bar
hot wet bar all over themselves until
they die from barfing and keel over into
a bottle of their own wet barf good
times so which one of these things is
the weirdest or was there something even
weirder than I missed or have I said the
word weird so many times that now weird
is weird to you let me know what you
think in the comments below you weirdos
jess is coming back next week but in the
meantime try not to bar okay
you